bonjour à tous honorine présenté un
nouveau smartphone d'entrée de gamme le
au nord 9 lite
c'est d'ailleurs assez surprenant parce
que fin d'année dernière ils ont déjà
présenté le honor celtics alors qu'est
ce que c'est au nord 9 lite à différents
par rapport au nord 7x qu'est ce qui est
mieux vu que les prix sont sensiblement
les mêmes
c'est ce qu'on va regarder
[Musique]
m
c'est un peu le bordel je me cache pas
je suis un peu perdue parce que au nord
brouille un peu les pistes
l'année dernière ils ont sorti le ono
review disent d'ailleurs j'ai fait une
vidéo test du hainaut review 10 juin
vital et la découvrir ici le au nord 7 x
l'année dernière et là le au nord 9 lite
j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre parce
que ces produits
le au nord 9 lite eléonore ctics sont
vraiment très très proches très
similaires donc ce qu'on va faire dans
cette vidéo c'est qu'on va comparer les
fiches techniques d'un côté du nord 7 x
de la côte est due aux normes 9 lite on
va regarder quelles sont les différences
significatives et en quoi est ce qui
pourrait vous intéresser
le horse et x6 les prix dans mes mains
il ya pas très longtemps au cs à las
vegas on a vraiment la sensation
d'immersion sur cet écran ratio 18/9 un
design plutôt sympa avec un nouveau
metal dassier le modèle bleu j'ai trouvé
que c'était un produit qui était plutôt
pas mal pistonné bien qu'effectivement
on consent pris un premier retrait de
gamme est plutôt bien c'est pas le
nouveau produit qui donne certes tombe à
la renverse
mais franchement je trouve qu'ils se
tient plutôt pas mal mais je suis
surpris pourquoi un au nord 9 lite
d'ailleurs au nord si vous regardez
cette vidéo
répondez moi je ne comprends pas
l'intérêt parce que c'est compliqué du
point de vue du consommateur de savoir
quels produits achetés il y en a
effectivement quedate de 2017 mais qui
est daté de décembre 2017 et un qui
arrive en février 2018
je comprends plus bon je prends ma fiche
et on regarde ça ensemble j'ai des notes
bien évidemment parce que je n'ai pas
appris les fiches techniques parker vous
en douterez c'est un peu compliqué la
grande différence que vous avez c'est
que le au nord 9 lite tourne sous
android 8.0 oreo alors que le 7x tourner
sur la version précédente le 7.0 nougat
normalement le 7x devrait pouvoir être
au gré des sourds oreo vous avez une
interface l'emotion ui là dessus aussi
le dense et xna pouvoir être gré des
côtés taille de l'écran c'est lui au
nord 7 x qui l'emportent avec une
diagonale de 5,93 pouces contre 5,75
pousse donc un peu plus de confort de
lecture dans les deux cas c'est une
dalle épaisse c'est donc du lcd la
définition et la même 2160 par 1080
pixels sont tous les deux même
processeur c'est lui qui rinne 659
cadencé à 2,6 gigahertz
la puce graphique c'est la même le nord
9 lite à 3 giga de ram tandis que le 7x
à 4 gigas de ram petite différence
je sais pas c'est dans l'utilisation de
ce produit ça changera vraiment grand
chose le stockage est un peu différent
le 9 lite à 32 giga le ctics à 64 gigas
dans les deux cas vous pouvez rajouter
une carte microsd pour monter la
capacité de stockage dans les deux cas
vous avez un double capteur à l'arrière
pour le 9 lite vous avez un capteur de
13 mégapixels et un capteur de 2
mégapixels le 2 méga pixels va servir
plus pour le flou pour vraiment détaché
les objets de l'autre côté sur le 7x
vous avez un 16 mégapixels et un 2
mégapixels nombre de pixels c'est pas ça
qui va réellement changer l'histoire
comme l'interface sera la même comme le
logiciel de traitement derrière sera le
même dans ma demande d'avoir des rendus
sensiblement similaire bonne différence
entre les deux sur le au nord de flight
vous avez également un doux de
l'appareil photo à l'avant ce sont les
mêmes que ceux que vous retrouve à
l'arrière un 13 mégapixels et un 2
mégapixels tandis que le 7x a uniquement
un seul appareil photo à l'avant un 8
mégapixels qui s'en tirera forcément
beaucoup moins bien non pour les photos
et les vidéos de celle fille mieux vaut
aller sur les honneurs 9 lite dans les
deux cas vous filmer en full hd 1920
1080 le bluetooth sur le neuf lights et
du 4 points 2 sur le celtic cdu 4.1 ça
change pas grand chose
que ce soit sur nos sols aux pouvait
mettre deux cartes sim la connectique
c'est du micro usb
le 9 lite et une batterie de trois mille
billions père earth est ce que le 7x à
une batterie des 3340 milliampères
heures en termes de poids c'est
sensiblement la même chose
le 9 lite est proposée en bleu noir gris
tandis que le 7x est proposée en bleu et
en noir donc d'un point de vue
spécifications techniques voyez c'est
vraiment des choses qui se tiennent dans
un mouchoir de poche d'un côté un os
avec un android d'hui toreo le côté 1,7
nougat d'un côté un plus grand écran de
l'autre un plus petit écran mais il n'y
a pas grand chose la vraie différence de
se faire un avis sur le dos sur les 9
lite vous avez un dos en verre à côté un
petit peu plus prévient par contre
effectivement va marquer au niveau des
traces de doigts il leur côté un peu
plus premium par rapport aux 7 x qui est
un dogme et al mais à part la différence
au niveau du dos la double caméra selphy
pour le 9 lite contre une seule caméra
celle fille pour le 7x
mise à part la différence d'écran ou le
celtic c'est une plus grande diagonale
que le 9 lite sinon les deux produits
sont similaires et même en termes de
prix il faut savoir qu'avec l'offre de
remboursement le 7x vous coûtera 249
euros et le 9 lite également avec
l'offre de remboursement 229 euros
vous avez 20 euros d'écart donc des
produits qui sont sensiblement
similaires qui ont sensiblement le même
prix qui ont l'air d'être plutôt pareil
j'essayais le 7x
il écoule gérer ce gagne à flight au mwc
je vous dirai ce que j'en pense mais
connaissant les produits de
or j'imagine que les deux se tiennent
vraiment dans un mouchoir de poche
j'ai vraiment du mal à comprendre la
différence d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce
que vous en pensez
est ce que vous comprenez un peu la
différence de positionnement de au nord
entre d'un côté le 9 lite et de l'autre
côté le 7x
je vous invite à marquer sans
commentaire parce que moi je suis un peu
largué merci en tout cas d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo je vous dites j'irais le
voir très prochainement j'irai l'essayer
je vous ferai un retour complet dessus
vous pouvez compter merci beaucoup soyez
sages comme d'hab vous invite à me
laisser des jeux les pousse à vous
abonner parce qu'on a toujours parlé
plus et toujours mieux de high tech
comme je vous le dis je vais aller au
mwc à barcelone qui est le temple de la
téléphonie mobile qui est un peu
l'équivalent du cs mais sur toute la
téléphonie mobile donc gilles allais
voir toutes les nouveautés les nouvelles
tendances les écrans les formes tout ce
qui existe tout ce qui existera demain
croyez moi je suis à l'affût et je vais
vous dire tout ça donc
abonnez vous à très bientôt merci à vous
soyez sages je vous embrasse
ciao